all right I'm gonna check out what that
gray smoke is first up just another fire
[ __ ] [ __ ] did you see me you might see
me definitely saw me definitely saw me
what was that noise
hello welcome to random encounter the
weekly live streaming show here on video
games com where I the Irish bloke from
that games website plays a random video
game today's random video game sir you
are being hunted yes you're being hunted
but not by humans or zombies or anything
else you're being hunted by the most
British ass robots you have ever seen
and they're amazing because when you
creep up on them they say little British
things what would robot accents all
right a little bit of exposition going
on here so let's jump right into it all
this is a bunch of robots all here's a
dude they don't see you from very far
but they tell all their buddies when
they do see you is this a one of the
spit it is all right I'm gonna check out
what that gray smoke is first up just
another fire [ __ ] [ __ ] did you see me
you might see me definitely saw me
definitely saw me all right going for
the boat and the bottom left is also the
visibility ah thingy he doesn't see me
anymore and when you crash you can
crouch to make stuff pretty invisible at
also in tall grass they were problem
seeing you because almost in a reverse
far cry move you're wearing a shirt so
that makes it look like you're actually
like I don't camouflages you I don't
know what these wisps are they are they
random that is just there to make you
more visible and is also this awesome
robot limp dude if you're hiding in the
bushes I need to scavenge more I feel I
feel like I'm doing a bad job of
scavenging I love games right we just
get to explore and there's like a decent
air of mystery oh hello great a weapon
do be careful with that I really think
violence is best left to the experts
it's gonna take some of these dubious
eggs oh [ __ ] did you see me [ __ ] yep all
right out of here I also think that like
the shotguns or the shots rather when
they ring out kind of collect a bunch of
other people who might be in the area or
I'm gonna try to Skyrim at down this
mountain this might be foolish goddammit
okay I'm okay I made it yeah there's a
bunch of them over there now okay I'm
gonna keep on this has had a shotgun
that would be even better oh my god are
you kidding me I'm like the nastradamus
of this game also pipe great to have any
actual it's got one round wonderful oh
that's pretty cool that is pretty cool
it was at him oh yeah it was like three
of them coming right towards me [ __ ]
okay I'm definitely able to kill three
of them so as far as i know you
definitely run faster than the robots
yes rifle ammo absolutely what's that
rock no apple shirt rash letter yes i'll
read that later man go go go go go go go
well automatically have the ammunition
for the I do okay that's good kind of
reload you your once you're one of those
old-time rifles aren't you Jesus oh [ __ ]
all right buddy I guess this is it
[ __ ] reload [ __ ] reload reload reload
one more bite at the cherry wait did I
down them today them there's two more
time [ __ ] yeah this thing's got some
pretty good splash damage going on
taking these guys out it's great sweet I
don't know how many more gonna come so I
better do this quick ah bag of mints
haha I'm taking you picking you fancy
gone [ __ ] I'm gonna have a kilt oh gosh
they're everywhere okay this is clearly
a much better shot gun than the one they
have but there's fires faster so i
better it's got some range as well this
is like our 2.1 no auto so many of them
oh Jesus I see I'm out of there I'm out
of there I'm bleeding I'm bleeding yeah
it's all right I'm out of there I'm out
of here and he does by I need to find
time to use those bandages
yes I would ah it might be best to run
and hide but if you have found a weapon
perhaps you can use it to fend them off
that was awesome let's make a
distraction I don't know how why this
thing goes so I'm gonna go 35 5 seconds
10 seconds 20 seconds [ __ ] Oh doesn't
matter now that his buddies find out the
hair dot yet it at all right [ __ ] this
Oh God [ __ ] there's like piss look EJ
car alright alright ok ok all right
different tactic this time that's why
those bastards are there right newnham
look at them you bastards all right I'm
gonna try and distract them this time
although I'm gonna read this letter
first father I received your reply and i
have to say to it worried me a bit I've
eaten the letter as you requested but
I'm still worried about you signing off
as dad give me a wisp show me a wisp now
I'm terrified I was walking around way
free earlier but now oh there's one I
don't tell me it's over there are you
kidding me god damn it what I really
want to do is get a shock and a blow
duck guy out of the air but I don't know
if that's possible I'm gonna throw this
[ __ ]
I think I heard them react to it are
they running over there please be
running please be running also you don't
come anywhere near me please okay
they're running over there they're
running over there oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
I'm bones oh I'm bones get the [ __ ] out
of here go go go I'm guessing every
robot on the island there knows where I
am yep they're all running after me oh
right is this thing still a nice little
nesting sites nope got that this is
pretty scary I want to get out of here
done a bit of gunplay we're making
progress you might survive this after
all I'm gonna eat this Apple yummy and
eat this mushroom sweet whoa much okay
the mushroom did something okay okay
it's cutting horse [ __ ] my cross hairs
gone sideways this is Christ yeah I'll
do that again I was fun yeah i was
watching cosmos last night this is what
Neil deGrasse Tyson said that the
animals saw the world when they came out
of the water Oh [ __ ] up on mushrooms
I'm gonna trade swimmer oh Jesus Christ
I scared the [ __ ] out of me
oh my god was i literally jumped in say
today yeah not cool what the [ __ ] is
that thing all right you got in here and
go to a different color different thing
oh my god ah oh oh oh turn off the thing
oh [ __ ] God that really does make you
visible cuz I'm in the light oh man
suppose British tea pot of all time I'm
taking you all there's loads there's
loads of artifacts a John there's not
one on each challenge I'm a silly boy
name is guy all right we got a couple
minutes left on this dream I'm gonna be
honest I one knock to see if I can kill
that dude in the blimp
if I use this I have notif and don't I
have no defense screw it screw it oh
hello oh there is hi Maddie misty
clubbin no tourists ha amazing hey
what's up that is sir you are being
hunted available right now on steam
fifteen percent off right now if you're
watching the highlights stream there is
another if you caught us within a day of
this going up on gamespot and it's still
enough for a fifty percent off thank you
very much watching rounded mckenna today
pleasure as ever if you have any
suggestions for next week's game at
Daniel Dwyer on the Twitter and put
until next week thank you very much for
watching at the point up on Friday will
be all about and a call of duty the new
one and we're shooting the whole thing
in the style of house of cards so it's
probably going to be really stupid
thanks for watching watching see you
guys next week I don't